Hey guys what's up so much awesome game of
thrones news we have the dig through.
We learned about a brand-new book that it's
coming at the end of the year that may have
tipped us off as to when winds of winter is
coming out in season 7 stuff, so if you been
gone for a while Be sure to click that bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss any game
of thrones videos and there is a new round
of the game of thrones giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's for
one of the enhanced editions of the books.
So people are just now learning about this,
but it's actually a pretty big deal it's all
about season 7 of game of thrones, leading
into a winds of winter release leading into
another short story set in the game of thrones
universe what I'm going to do is explain what's
going on with a winter update and then talk
about what this other brand-new story inside
the world of a song of ice and fire's going
to be because a lot of people feel like it's
going to be part of the fire in blood Targaryen
history book.
George RR Martin is making he's got a warehouse
of Targaryen material that he's written for
other books that's been cut out, just waiting
to be included in this big Targaryen anthology.
So the really big thing first people of been
pounding Reddit the watchers, everybody that
follows game of thrones book news have found
out that George RR Martin is contributing
to a short story book that's being released
at the end of this year that is called the
book of swords thing about this that's really
important for winds of winter is the timing
of the book release because originally it
was going to come out sometime early in 2017
with the planned release of winds of winter
originally they were going to release the
wins a winter book early in 2017 and the idea
that everyone has figured out is that this
short story just because it's not quite as
big a deal would ride on the coattails of
that release.
So when the way the books feed the show.
The show feeds the book release the bigger
books feed the smaller books it's all one
thing at a time.
So I'll explain what this new Targaryen stuff
that he might be including in this book, is
but it just means because game of thrones
season 7 is dropping late June.
They don't have an exact date yet but all
signs are pointing towards late June.
Just a couple months based on the time they
started shooting that the couple months after
when they would normally start shooting.
It's all just a matter of playing the date
they started shooting about three or so months
later than they normally would.
So the season is gonna come out.
Three months later than it normally would
which would be in April, so now it's in June.
So no worries.
It just means game of thrones season 7 party
happening all summer, but because wins a winter
has been delayed in this new book is coming
out at the end of the year it just points
to a wins a winter release at the end of the
summer like a little after game of thrones
season 7 ends before the winter starts.
So use have to imagine that from about the
middle of June all the way towards the end
of the year will just be dominated by game
of thrones material both the TV show and the
books.
And because there shooting schedule is going
to be similar to season 7 the season eight
release will be about the same will be quite
as bad as the weight between season six and
season 7 plus will have all this new wins
a winter short story song of ice and fire
material to dig through you have to imagine
that there's an order of magnitude more book
material then there is show material there
might be 10 hours of TV show in a normal season
that there's hundreds of hours worth of material
in one of the books.
So there is so much game of thrones stuff
happening later this year to get excited about
in this is something I should really talk
about in another bonus video, but Martin has
said that he will be including a whole bunch
of stuff in the new books that they will never
be able to do on the TV show so people that
are upset that Stannis is dead on the TV show
like he has some big, big twist that he's
teasing her wins a winter that they'd never
be able to do on the TV show so is like 1/2
you kill my characters that are still alive
in the books I'm in a do some stuff that you
can never get away with, so for those that
are worried that the TV show will eventually
spoil the books, there's a lot of the books
that will be completely different from the
TV show, but the really important book stuff
for those you asking what's going on with
wins a winter to confirm preview chapters
that he's either read from or released the
POV characters that we know about or Aeron
great joys the dam pair Arianne Martel who
is not a TV show character arias Stark barest
and sell me may he rest in peace on the TV
show Sansa start feeling great joy Tyrion
who he's actually previewed to chapters from
wins a winter and then Vic Tyrion great joy.
So lately he's also revealed that Cersei is
going to get a chapter bran Stark is going
to get a chapter in area who does good to
get a chapter 2 but because he does cut out
a lot of things when he's editing books down
some of those people might get pushed to dream
of spring, which is gonna be the next book
after wins a winter.
So if you're TV show person who is new to
the books.
George R Martin will release samples of chapters
before the actual books are done, so when
we get to the next book when were waiting
for the game of thrones spinoff to start.
It will be lots of sample chapters from dream
of spring to tide us over to what all do this
year is I will do a separate video for all
the wins a winter preview chapters because
I will be doing book videos when the books
come out most of my videos tend to be TV show
videos just because that's what you most of
my subscribers come from from the TV show
that they'll be lots of book stuff happening
later this year.
Meanwhile the new fire and blood Targaryen
story.
The reason for making this video that sort
of bled people to find out when wins a winter
is probably coming out is most likely going
to be material that he cut out from the dance
of the Dragon saga that he's been writing
novellas for so if you haven't been reading
the books.
The dance of the dragons is the story of a
Targaryen Civil War that he's published a
couple of smaller books about, so he cut up
a bunch of material for that.
The first one is the Princess and the Queen.
It's based on the real-life war of the roses
in English history then later he published
another book.
It was a prequel to that call the rope prints
that was about the Sarris the first Targaryen
leading into that conflict, so a lot of you
been asking about the game of thrones spinoff,
maybe it will cover this.
In Targaryen history because he's written
so much about it and it involves so much Dragon
writing is basically a.
When a lot of the Targaryen family were writing
Dragon before they died off.
You have all the craziness of a normal game
of thrones story, with the added bonus of
crazy Dragon Rider battles because dragons
were such a big deal this.
It also deals with Dragon bonding he gets
into more of the Lord of game of thrones that
he hasn't spelled out on the TV show or in
the main books yet either.
In fact, it's such a big deal that HBO themselves
produce some bonus content like a featurette
detailing one of the big encounters during
this war.
So this is actually narrated by the actor
the plays Oberyn Martell may he rest in peace
14 days later the shuttle blacker than an
awesome cloud swept over Heron Hall Sagar
come the and on her back reload one night
print statement a multitude even for facing
him alone.
You have lived too long.
Uncle and David replied on that much we agree
than the old prints climb stiffly onto the
back of his truck and corrections but neglected
to fuss the chains secure to the son was close
to said when S1 demon to practice up swiftly
from two they disappeared into a bank of clouds
figure on the slope ascended up in the figure
sword searching for Carozza's suddenness of
fun shrieking crocs just dove on for God loved
the truck and stumbled toward the lake precious
just close the config arsenic take a break
open Carozza Spinney and her teeth reaped
off and we rushed up with terrible speed then
they been putting in quick never fuss his
writing chains student in his subtle he leapt
from his truck into Inhumans and in his hand
was dark sister the valyrian.
Sort of Aegon's sister Queen is England one.
I looked up the entire Damon ripped off his
nephews him and drew the sword down to his
one remaining I.
So the point about the back of the young Princess
half a heartbeat later the dragons struck
the sending of accountable for.
So sent to have been stone close Greektown
Lake with Dragon.
So mortgages written a lot about that.
In history that's why people think this secret
new book is going to be about that but the
other big theory is that it's going to be
new dunk and Egg from the fourth book he said
he's going to write after wins a winter comes
out.
If you don't know what that is.
I've done videos about dunk and Egg before
so I link to that at the end of this, but
there only three books right now.
He said he's going to continue those.
So it will be a much bigger story is not can
it do that till after he delivers wins of
winter that new dunk and Egg book is supposed
to be called the she wolves of winter fell
so they'll get you really excited that takes
place about 100 years before the events on
the game of thrones TV show two I know everybody
loves the Targaryen family.
They have such a rich crazy history is so
fun to read about but the history of winter
fell in the Stark family is also super important
to since the TV show revealed that the night
King was the first man I know a lot of you
are asking if he was part of the Stark family,
that will be my next bonus video that I'll
post this Sunday.
So it can be really exciting that is awesome
is the idea of new start history is it's more
likely that he just going to pull from the
pile of his Targaryen edits and just include
that is one of the short stories.
So it's not he's writing new material instead
of doing wins a winter for the short book.
It just that he has all the stuff that he's
cut out.
The just like copy and pasted into this new
short story book.
So, I know now some your like wait a minute
what is all this material that he's cutting
out we want to read this.
This is great stuff will include all this
in separate books what will probably happen
like he's done in the past he always publishes
short novellas as he's working on the big
new song of ice and fire books leading into
dream of springlike well after wins a winter
comes out will probably find ways to release
all this material that he's cut out in short
blurbs as he goes along.
So even if it takes another six years to get
that last game of thrones book he'll be releasing
new game of thrones book content every single
year he does that every year.
So don't freak out too much but to get really
excited because there will be a lot of new
song of ice and fire book material coming
out this year after season 7 drops in of course
I'll be giving away copies of the book right
now the enhanced additions are like the brand-new
shiny things that's with the giveaways or
four, but once the new books come out.
That's what the giveaway so be for let me
know what you guys think about the idea of
him releasing all this new game of thrones
stuff at the end of the year.
I feel like it's the best possible news and
people been waiting so long for new song of
ice and fire, in addition to waiting for TV
show stuff to drop.
But now sound like it's all happening all
at the same time later this year is gonna
be crazy.
Congratulations to the new game of thrones
giveaway winner Ruben Avalos you and a copy
of one of the enhanced editions of the books
please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There's new Star Wars episode 8 posting tonight.
But new game of thrones on Sunday while you
wait for that you can click here to learn
about extra episodes in season eight like
brand-new stuff and you can click here to
learn all about dunk and Egg.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you in the next video!